GOOD FEED,Bob:  SO GOOD, USING
STICK TO PREVENT CHANCES IN THE
AIR, AND HE SCORES.
I THINK IT COUNTS, MEARSY.
I THINK -- I DON'T KNOW IFIT GO
YOUR THRONE OUT FRONT TO
BARKOV.
EKBLAD CHEWTON SCORES. ,  RECKL
IF YOU WILL.
HERE IS THE LAST SHOT OFF THE
>> Steve: FLORIDA PK, 10 FOR 10
OVIN.
FINAL TWO MINUTES OF THIS. ABLE
CIRCLE P LOOKING AT FRONT, AND
EKBLAD AT
HUBERDEAU.
GOT
CONTACT.
REINHART  WAS TRYING TO MOVE
OUT OF THAT AREA.
WHERE THE PUCK WAS.
BODIES, AND TRAFFIC.
USUALLY, GOOD CONVERSATION.
PLAYS
THAT TAKES YEARS AND YEARS OF
PRACTICE THE
>> Steve: RODRIGUES HAD THAT'S
OVER TO VERHAEGHE.
HE'S GOT IT LOOSE PUCK, AND THE
KEPT IT ALIVE, FLORIDA DID,
POKING AT IT, GREAT JOB DENYING
THE ENTRY.
COUNTERATTACK BY BARKOV.THIS NE
THE LEAD IN HAPPY CROSBY, HE